need motivation
watch top 10 video and leave nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was designed to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself so get
ready for some mindset manifesting
advice from Sara Blakely to give you the
motivation confidence and belief that
you need
ok let's kick it off with real number
one manifest your idea I wanted to be a
lawyer
and I'm a terrible test taker after I
basically bombed the LSAT I hate tried
out at Disney World to be goofy and you
have to be 5-8 and I'm only 5 6 so I'm
the height of a chipmunk which was like
I guess you could say sort of felt a
little bit like rock bottom I wasn't
gonna be a lawyer and I was too short to
be goofy there was a moment when I was
selling fax machines door to door and I
was constantly being escorted out of
buildings or sometimes people would rip
up my business card in my face which was
a typical occurrence and one day I
pulled off the side of the road and I
literally thought I'm in the wrong movie
like this is not my life cut called a
director called the producer how did
this happen this is not supposed to be
in my life I went at home that day and
wrote at in my apartment in my notebook
what my strengths were and the only
thing basically in the strengths call
him that I was sure about was sales and
I said ok and what can I do with that
and I ended up writing I want to invent
a product that I can sell to millions of
people that will make them feel better
and it was 2 years later that I cut the
feet out of control top pantyhose to
wear white pants to a party whoo number
2 take a different approach I think that
there's there's you know traditional
business has been very masculine and
it's been a very masculine model and so
I approach it I mean and when I say that
I when I first started Spanx I was maybe
three months in and I was at a cocktail
party and I these three guys came up to
me and they said Sarah so we heard you
invented something and I said yes I did
and they said great and one guy you know
pat me on the shoulder and he said I
hope you're ready to go to war and he
said business is war and I just remember
looking at him and thinking
why and I went home that night and sat
in my apartment and I sat on the floor
and I was thinking about all that was
happening and you know this risk I was
taking and potentially leaving my debt
job and the secure income and and just
thinking I don't want to go to war and
this voice inside of my head just said
do it different like take a totally
different approach and so I have
approached Spanx with very feminine
principles and there's there's the
feminine and the masculine in all of us
and it's all super important but you
know using vulnerability really
operating off of intuition if the data
is trumping my intuition I go with my
intuition almost every time so you know
that's not typical in in a corporate
environment so those kinds of things
that I've done like being vulnerable
with the business I am I felt as a
consumer I just felt like companies
aren't really talking to me the way that
I want them to talk to me I know I'm not
listening to them I don't believe them I
don't necessarily trust them and so when
I started Spanx I instead of talking you
know at my customer I wanted to talk to
them and I made myself vulnerable so I
like I joked and said I used my own but
in the before and after picture but I
had felt like companies were operating
in this like we need to be perfect and
you need to see us as the authority and
you need me and that's how I'm gonna
sell you product and I was like hey like
I'm one of you like here's here's what's
happening here's what it does for me
this is why it works and it was just a
very different approach and I felt like
consumers became really connected and
really loyal and probably part of the
reason why Spanx as a brand didn't need
to advertise for six I mean three we
haven't spent any money on advertising
in 16 years because of a lot of it's
word of mouth from women sharing with
other women rule number three make the
best product the process of me cutting
the feet out of my pantyhose while
trying to get the prototype made before
I launched it was two years so there was
a year solid of me driving in North
Carolina
on the weekends and at night or taking
time off from work to go and work on the
prototype get it made I learned so many
things that I didn't know as a consumer
it had never dawned on me you know that
men were making all of our undergarments
so I learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between a small and an
extra-large and putting the same
waistband on every pair exactly that's
nice that I said you know that's not
working we're really uncomfortable and
they were doing it to cut cost in
productions so I immediately changed
that in a Spanx waistband a size small
gets a small medium gets a medium and so
on makes perfect sense right I also
realized that they had been putting a
tiny rubber cord inside the waist bands
that had been there forever well we had
made so many advancements in yarns that
they no longer needed the rubber cord
but no one had stopped to say do we
still need to put this so I immediately
took the rubber cord out of it and
another thing I learned was the way that
they were doing sizing was just so blew
me away they would figure out his size
by putting them on plastic forms and
they would all put it on a plastic form
they had different size forms and they
would stand back with their clipboards
and go yep that's the size medium and
I'd lean in and I go ask her how she
feels so it's thanks we put our product
on women my mother my grandmother who's
90 my sister-in-law caste I mean all of
my friends the girls at spanks we're
testing it on real women and we want to
test it more than two seconds to say yep
that looks like a medium we we have
people wear it for a week wash it tell
us if it rolled did it move did it stay
in place how did you feel very concerned
with Spanx garments and how they made
you feel before don't give up I went
online and looked up manufacturers that
made undergarments and hosiery type
products
I called them on the phone and didn't
get anywhere and eventually I took a
week off of work and drove around North
Carolina begging all of these men
ironically that we're making our
undergarments to help try to make this
new type of undergarment I went in
unannounced
I had no appointment so you can imagine
how that went most of them is corded me
out and said good luck I got a phone
call about two weeks later from one of
the manufacturer owners and he said Sara
I have decided to help make your crazy
idea I ran it by my three daughters at
the dinner table and they told me I
should give you a shot also if you want
to learn from other successful women
entrepreneurs check in my 2:54 girlboss
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below when I was selling
copiers door-to-door I had a very clear
vision of what my life was gonna be like
from day one I just I never tried to
hide that I was the girl in my apartment
with the red backpack rule number five
change your mindset banks started way
before I cut the feet out of my
pantyhose that's the sound bite in the
press that everybody's talked about for
almost 20 years but it actually started
fundamentally on when I was 16 I worked
on mind set for myself and I'm such a
believer in mind set is almost
everything and it just happened to be a
set of circumstances I was riding my
bike with one of my best friends at 16
and she was run over by a car and killed
in front of me and then a few months
later my dad left home and my parents
separated and ultimately got divorced
and when my dad moved out he came into
my bedroom and he handed me a cassette
tape series called how to be a No Limit
person by Wayne Dyer and he said sweetie
I wish I discovered this when I was your
age instead of the age of 40 and then he
moved out and so I started listening to
this how to be a No Limit person which
was talking about visualization law of
attraction not caring about what other
people think about you the fear you know
not being consumed by the fear of
failure and it's just the clouds parted
for me and I thought you know I've spent
a lot of time being taught what to think
but no one's really teaching me how to
think and at 16 I was so incredibly
important so in
this digital platform it's kind of
passing on a lot of these insights that
deal with mindset that I think is the
real reason that Spanx exists
rule number six stand out from the crowd
the packaging what am I gonna do for the
packaging I knew I thought as a consumer
I didn't know anything else I'd never
actually taken a marketing class either
in my life
but I knew as a consumer I was
frustrated I was going into the hosiery
departments and everything looked the
same
it was the same beige package or the
same way packaged with the same
half-naked woman that been on there for
30 years and I couldn't tell what I was
buying so I said to myself I'm gonna do
this different I wanted to be my
favorite color red no one had ever done
red in the hosiery space before I wanted
to be bold stand out I knew that if I
got a chance to be on the shelf with no
money to advertise it had to jump out
and say I'm new I'm different try me
so I put three animated Illustrated
cartoon women on the package which had
also never been done before there'd only
ever been photography on these hosiery
packages I was working on it every night
after work on my friend's computer she
had just finished graphic design school
so I would come home and we would sit
side by side and I was cutting out lips
and eyes and I was very you know decided
about how to make it
design-wise I wanted it to feel like you
were buying a present for yourself
instead of a commodity that we dreaded
rule number seven redefined failure
growing up my dad used to encourage my
brother and me to fail so at the dinner
table he would actually ask us what did
you fail at this week and if we didn't
have something to tell him he would
actually be disappointed and I can
remember coming home from school me like
dad dad I tried out for this and I was
horrible and he'd be like way to go and
high-five me and what it was such a gift
what he was doing I didn't realize that
at the time but he was redefining
failure for me and so failure became not
about the outcome but about not trying
and so you know the fear of failure as
we all know as entrepreneurs is one of
the greatest fears in life it's one of
the things that stops us in our tracks
and keeps us from trying something
and so I you know I incorporate that in
my philosophy at Spanx we have we
celebrate failures we talk about them we
have oops meetings we're all announced
the oops that I have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach theme
songs to our oops and we'll play them in
front of the whole company but I think
it's just so important to try to get the
people that you work with to take risks
and to be entrepreneurial and not live
in a place of I want to protect my job
and feel like I'm not safe if I make
mistakes rule number eight ask questions
many aspiring entrepreneurs even in this
room struggle to find their initial idea
how do you constantly find ways to
invent new products and where does your
inspiration come from you know I I mean
I think of a lot of ideas at traffic
lights I think of them all the time in
different places and I think it's part
of just being hyper observant I I like
to find white space I pay attention to
what are things that haven't evolved and
why you know like there's certain things
in our society that updates itself and
changes and and you know constantly and
then there's certain things that it's
not and so I'll ask myself questions all
day every day it's just the way my brain
works like I could even be looking at a
table and be like why is the table like
that
when was the table first created is that
the actual best design for a table or
could there be something different and
you know what Spanx went into men's and
that was randomly how that happened was
because I got curious that the man's
undershirt was created in 1918 and no
one had paid any attention to it since
it was literally the same thing and so I
just you know talked to my brother and
my husband about it and their
undershirts that the neck stretched out
or they were boxy and bulky under
clothes and I thought oh I'm just gonna
add a little bit of lycra to the cotton
undershirt for men and so the neck won't
stretch out I'm gonna taper it in at the
waist so ideas come to me like that
ideas I really hope clearly I love I
have my assistant who's my right hand
lisa is she's been my right hand for 16
years can attest to this but I have 99
pages I don't know why it's 99 but she
told me the other day it's 99 pages
single spaced typed of ideas
one more idea so ie I think of ideas
constantly on airplanes in car you know
talking to somebody and I email it to
myself and then I just keep them and
logged them rule number nine do your
research
okay so I've written the patent I'm
submitting it I have the prototype I'm
getting it almost perfect to where I
want it to be I got to come up with a
name so I had been writing down on scrap
pieces of paper for that entire year
really bad names in my car on a plane
you know pulling off the side of the
road and finally I narrowed down my
thinking on what I wanted to name my
invention by this I recognized that the
two most recognized names in the world
at the time were Kodak and coca-cola so
I started playing with them in my mind
why are they the two most recognized
names in the world what do they have in
common and they both have a significant
K sound to them and I actually had read
that the man who started Kodak liked the
K sound so much that he put the K in the
beginning and the end of the word and
started playing with letters in the
alphabet to come up with the word Kodak
I also knew that you know coca-cola had
such a strong case presence to it and I
have a bunch of friends that are
stand-up comedians and it's this just
this weird trade secret among comedians
that the K sound will make your audience
laughs so it was determined for good
luck my invention was going to have the
K sound in it and I added it I I decided
okay once I decided that I was clearer
on my thinking for the name it came to
me while sitting in traffic in Atlanta I
got very lucky I was sitting there and
just the word Spanx came across the
dashboard and at the very last second I
went home and I knew it was right and I
changed the KS to an X at the last
minute because I had done research that
made up words do better for products
than real words do and they're also
easier to trademark I didn't tell one
person the name I got on USPTO govt
which stands for United States Patent
and Trademark Office gov which was my
best friend at the time I was always on
that website
I did a search I entered my credit card
and for I think 250 or $300 I hit Send
and I owned the name Spanx a month later
I got it in the mail and rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is embrace adversities the biggest
hurdles for me as a woman in business
were also my greatest strengths and that
was being underestimated many times in
the journey being underestimated made it
harder for me to get the men and the
manufacturing plants to take my ideas
seriously or to even give me a chance
but it was also a real competitive
advantage for me growing the company I
continued to really embrace the being
underestimated as a woman and I've been
able to stay true to the feminine
principles in leadership and throughout
growing Spanx now I've got a special
bonus tip from Sara on how to have a
mission that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to redefine the
failures you've had number two where do
you need to do more research and number
three what are you never going to give
up on what role do you hope the Sara
Blakely foundation will play in the
empowerment of women well I mean my
ultimate goal is that the male and
female energy on the planet becomes
balanced so I feel like all right well
good that one person who agrees with me
yeah so anyway the male and female
energy on the planet more balanced and
the reason why I say energy I mentioned
earlier is that we all have the male and
the female energy inside of us and I
feel like the feminine has been pretty
squashed for a long time on our planet
and it's not serving the greater whole
so what can I do in my short lifetime to
elevate the feminine and and that's what
the foundation is focused on in how can
I help be elevating and supporting that
and I take my opportunity as a woman in
this country so seriously
and I think part of the reason that I do
is because I got to watch my mom and my
grandmothers and their lack of options
and that was really hard and so you know
we've been on the planet for thousands
of years or millions of years depending
on who you ask and what you think but
the bottom line is my mom is only twenty
two years older than me and my mom had
about three or four options only
afforded to her because she was a woman
so in the grand scheme of life and how
long we been on earth I'm like I made it
by 22 years like what you're kidding me
so I feel like a lot of my courage and
you know I'm scared of a lot of things I
mean I'm afraid to fly I'm afraid of
heights like I've got all kinds of
things but I feel like where I get my
courage is that Retta knowing and
thinking about I'm a woman born in the
right place at the right time I don't
want to squander that
if you want 10 more awesome rules from
Sarah check out their video right there
next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
my life was not great I was selling fax
machines door-to-door I was living with
my mom I was like 25 years old I'm in of
the belief system